hello and welcome to this video playing
a mile exam well I have a terrible
school against this person why if minus
5 that's not good we get an open that I
generally like to play some Hedgehog
I don't be too quick but quickly t7 is
very likely no no this one also quite
known only in my gym this one and should
cover C 3 so that D 5 and B 5 are not
happening all that all that quickly
[Music]
okay okay that's a very very comfortable
position let's see he cannot play now
play either d5 or b5 and his position is
pretty clocked up with the night only
aid it's close you even Knight f5
something like that is close it takes 95
it takes rook and Bishop it's okay to
move the bishop
but yeah f5 is just around the corner
maybe I could have played it before yeah
I I think something like g6 is very
likely to happen yeah certainly
so what's going on here a couple of good
options repeat very good position for
wide even the immediate h5 is possible
but first I'm going to put this on g3
Ruki 194 would be noise I wonder if he
actually manages to play this if I would
defy I'm a I don't think so
look see a dope the one I'm still having
it covered okay I have to get out of
there for f6 is very weakening
threatening 94 either night actually so
and yeah here we should be three he
comes into consideration before is also
good more tough to same it's also good
it's going for you cannot take it and
after the capture that will be a
favorable pawn structure
let's see I'm not quite sure how to
proceed just age six
probably just age six Cline next playing
this next pushing them completely back
try to then try to put pressure on these
six like cannot move any of his pawns
that sells an issue okay one is probably
one still 97 so sacrifices are close
we need to nose to working with I think
I can just line this up 94 c5 before
traps the rook I don't see move early
for black if I take f5
[Music]
yeah that's possible but okay if I take
it and so after this what will he doing
yeah B should be 3 is also winning the
exchange
now let's see Knight f5 looks quite
powerful not wasting any time but this
is also good threatening right e7 and 90
X at five so okay let's do this
now cheeks f5 yeah I cannot so just take
this that's right oh good move for black
kind to grab c5 check
okay now the H 1 the H pawn is dangerous
okay
so so hanging on somehow
time warning
how some of this is not falling apart
immediately it's amazing okay
black radar had to fall apart at some
point at that position all of the
opening I think is close to unplayable
really so this is still okay but I think
that it's create eight year that that
leads to trawl and the engine actually
agrees with this yeah I don't like the
position anyway but after Queen eight
it's definitely problematic
again this is a completely one-sided
position where white can just press and
black can do absolutely nothing
now yeah maybe there are ways to improve
for white which I don't know you know
here this is just an extremely favorable
structure here like this oops sorry
yeah that's just extremely favorable
flex pieces are completely completely
boxed in I will 95 well that's a cool
move Wow
so kia 3 wasn't good check okay I'm
using tons of porn sites if that's true
oh no I DJ system point hmm
it's not another scare position that's
true and that's what he should have done
he never went for any of those
sacrifices yeah I should have taken that
five probably yeah I wasn't completely
sure here I thought I saw this but I
wasn't totally sure I thought that it
could be good to Hanson but it was it
was quicker then when I did I mean this
is also completely winning but so so
continues for a while yeah in general I
think that it's much easier if you'd
like to play with d5 in such a position
on the the head shop here it's of course
playable but I think it's a fairly
favorable version for one okay guys
thanks over for watching